let's talk about this this is a crazy
story boy switzerland may jail people
who turn their heat above 66 degrees
this winter well good oh most people
want to warm their homes
they think they are this planet is warm
enough
citizens of switzerland who dare turn
their thermostats above a balmy 19
degrees celsius or 66 degrees fahrenheit
perfect temperature if you ask me over
the winter may instead find themselves
shipping shivering in a prison cell the
cause of natural gas in europe has
increased more than tenfold you guys see
that in italy they're doing things by
candlelight now at bars and restaurants
those who failed to comply with the
temperature mandates could receive
sanctions between thirty and three
thousand swiss francs the equivalent of
thirty one and three thousand ninety
dollars
federal department of finance spokesman
marcus
spjorn
told the outlet those found
intentionally violating the statute
would receive up to three years in
prison this is the next lockdown the
climate lockdown yeah and they're going
to implement it through smart cities and
smart meters you know a couple years ago
we saw people screaming they're
installing the smart meters don't do it
they're going to control everything and
people thought they were crazy and now
when we see stories like this
and how people are having their heat
turned off because they're they're you
know turning the heat up too much it
really puts things into a perspective
that i think is worth considering
especially with how technology is being
more involved in our everyday lives and
how central controllers are using it to
track trace and data it's kind of
amazing you know they say climate change
and all that stuff you got to buy
electric cars and electric cars are
really bad for the environment
so uh yeah i i got a tesla we went to a
supercharger and i plug it in and i'm
sitting there and i'm looking at the
cost and it was like
it was half the cost of gas half like
you think it's going to be cheap not
only did it take 20 minutes to recharge
the car but we ended up spending i think
it was like 20 bucks to like fill up to
like recharge and i was like okay well
that's cheaper than gas but it's still
i'm pulling up to a gas station plugging
in spending 20 bucks on my credit card i
was like what's the advantage here then
i can't go that far and the government
cannot turn my car off whenever they
want nice do you feel do you feel that
it's people that genuinely believe in
climate change and genuinely believe in
the the future of the world being
overheated or do you feel like this is
just power driven i don't know man i
think this is going into there's a big
agenda in the un 2030 vision which is
also pictured by the build back better
great reset world economic forum vision
they share the same vision it's
essentially the same thing they just
kind of rebrand it for marketing
purposes and their vision is of course
getting rid of cars and if you look at
major cities and the way that they've
been developing they've been getting rid
of people's ability to drive cars when
you drive a car you have freedom you
have the ability to go anywhere you want
they they want people stuck in cities
dependent on public transportation
essentially that is the end goal that
they are reaching for because then you
could have total enslavement of people
that can't escape that can't run away
and when you look at their their goals
they they they're they're already
implementing it it's not cost effective
to have a car in new york city insurance
rates are crazy speed cameras everywhere
you go roads are being turned into
pedestrian sidewalks traffic jams are
absolutely crazy and i think you know
there's there's there's a there's a big
portion of individuals who want to get
rid of cars because it's bad for the
environment but there's also a lot of
people who want to control people and
they're such control freaks that they
want to get rid of your ability to be
able to travel yeah
well it's very american like the idea of
the automobile right like detroit and
muscle cars and the interstate and just
being able to have that mobility and
that freedom to go exactly and it's it's
so i'm wondering like you know because i
i don't know what the elites the powers
that be really think do they really
believe that cars are killing the planet
or is it just making
people believe that cars are killing the
planet in order to have power over them
for me
no no go ahead go no so for me it's like
this more than anything is an indictment
on the centralization of public
education
because the fact of the matter is like
you know
a lot of people legitimately think it's
unfathomable or inconceivable
that our government will have
you know doesn't have our best interest
in mind and so to the extent that a
government like you know in switzerland
would you know
crack down on the way in which people
kind of regulate the temperature in
their home
rather than thinking of this as a kind
of tyrannical thing
many people unfortunately think of this
as the government having our best
interest in mind and so you know it for
me it is leading up to luke's point to
kind of a globalist agenda i mean for
example with you know king charles kind
of taking the throne in england he did
talk about climate change and he said
that this is an issue that can't be
fixed by a singular country
it can only be fixed by a coming
together of all the nations and so this
is kind of like a
rhetoric that's leading to
the kind of groundwork or the threshold
of a kind of globalist agenda you know
what i mean and so um hopefully i didn't
mess with the algorithm but um that's
definitely what they're building up
toward you know yeah
they can turn your car off whenever they
want and drive it wherever they want to
yeah so so that's crazy because you hear
about people in these random car
accidents right oh but now with like a
tesla for instance you'll be like
sitting in your car and you'll be
driving and then
you know a warrant will come out for
your arrest or something like let's say
you were
you you
are accused of doing something you
didn't do whatever you stole a package
or something like that you didn't do it
but they show a warrant for your arrest
because of it you're driving in your car
and all of a sudden it goes
and then it's like sorry dave you're
being detoured to the local police
station
and then it's like auto locks engaged
please sit back and remain calm and then
your car just slows down and turns
around you're like what i you can't get
out pulls up to the police station
they're out there waiting with their
guns ready and out of the vehicle your
car just arrested you for us
yeah i believe there's already stories
of of people's teslas being repossessed
by using the feature where the car
drives to you i i summon summoned to to
people repossessing them i need to do
research on that but i remember hearing
about that months ago specifically but
this is why you always have a glass
breaker uh or every whenever you can for
that possibility that distinction but i
i do think there's multiple layers here
there's the environment level there's
the control level but there's also
trying to get rid of the power level the
model s is a cabin camera
so not only do they have cameras
surrounding the vehicle and it's
convenient it's because with so uh
parking and such yeah when you park you
can pull up the app and then you can
take a look and see the cameras from
anywhere because it connects to the cell
network and then you connect to the
network and then you're good so you can
park your car you can be in another
state and you can pull up your car's
cameras but they also have a cabin
camera i don't know if all of them have
the center the model s has it filming
you yep and it's going to the internet
it's going to tesla's servers
now you can choose to watch it but it
means they're getting that footage too
and so it's a convenience it's that way
when you're driving you have the dash
cam and the cabin camera if you get an
accident then we all know what happened
and also they know exactly what you're
doing whenever and they can subpoena you
may you may be thinking yeah but tesla's
not going to get it to the government
they will when they're told they have to
when when some fbi agent goes to someone
says we want to look inside their car
right now and then it does and then
you're driving in your vehicle and they
and they decide your car just stops the
doors lock you can't get out here's
here's the other thing the model s has
the bio hazard filter mode or whatever
where it like seals the air and then
blasts you with like 99.99
filtered air then you're really locked
in and you can't get out well i always
thought it was strange like you know
because i don't really know where elon
musk is at you know i haven't done a lot
of research on him
but it's like this idea of like you know
turning your home solar putting a a
tesla battery grid in your home
that charges your car
and then your car is actually becomes
your wi-fi right yeah as you're
connected to the starling satellites and
your brain chip is activated so
you're looking at one company that now
controls your your your energy
your transportation and your
communication yeah you know i mean the
minds but it's just like you know and i
know a lot of people kind of get on the
elon musk you know i i haven't like
again i haven't done a lot of research
in it but that's a lot of power to give
to one company well hold on how cool
would it be if neural link comes out and
you can get a brain implant thing that
can you know you put you click your your
chip into your brain and then you can
learn all the stuff but then what ends
up actually happening is you know all of
a sudden everyone like they put it on
and they go no but i love elon musk i am
one with musk and then we're like
fighting off zombies and they're like
join the musk and you're like no then
everyone's like they're trying to put
the implant in your neck
be one one with us and then elon's like
i am in charge now you are all my
children and then you know that's just
the reality that's that would be a good
we should make a movie we should make a
a sci-fi horror i did like the
photographs that uh the meme that was a
gas powered generator charging a tesla
in california this week that was really
funny
yeah cuz what are you gonna do there's a
there's a funny babylon bee thing where
it's like
uh california makes you charge your car
by hamster wheel or whatever
it's especially funny when you
understand i believe the second law of
thermodynamics in that you're better off
just running somewhere instead of trying
to run to charge the car to drive the
car somewhere but i suppose the idea is
if you run for like 40 hours you'll have
enough to bring your groceries back from
the grocery store or something like that
there's another company i'm trying to
find right now that that is also
launching its own auto drive feature and
to do it they have a camera
on the driver who's driving the car to
make sure that his eyes are on the road
and his hands are on the wheel and if
they're not it it auto takes off the the
you know auto driver what's the point of
auto driving if the car can't auto drive
you know what's really annoying is in
the honda they have i think most new
cars have this they have the lane assist
thing and so you're driving and then
you'll see like uh like a skunk or
something oh i gotta go a little to the
left and it goes
like leaving the lane it freaks out and
then forces you back i'm like dude don't
take the wheel from me trying to not hit
the turtle that was trying to cross the
street you know turtles are going all
slow and what are you supposed to do
just run it over yeah it's definitely
scary that they can they can shut off
your car and and have that kind of power
over you so yeah that's why i'm really
excited i'm looking into cars from the
60s yeah yeah well those mines are
cheaper too yeah they might have carbon
legal at one point right i mean that's
the whole point yeah again it's like
america and the american spirit is kind
of a car culture you know we are a
mobile society like we you know we
really um innovated cars and and and not
in the interstate you know this the idea
of having the freedom to hit the road
you know kind of like the jack kerouac
kind of spirit of just going around the
country but now you're seeing more like
live work spaces mass transit
pods pods yeah thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you